Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch.
Ich denke, dass der Fußball an sich natürlich schon wunderbar erzählerisches Material hat. Das ist natürlich auch klar. Ich kann auch verstehen, dass man sagt, ich guck mir lieber 90 Minuten im Stadion an, als auf der Kinoleinwand. Aber andererseits, die größeren Überraschungsmomente sind inzwischen tatsächlich im Kino zu sehen. Um mal überrascht zu werden, was Tolles zu erleben und in Staun zu kommen, sollte man sich einen Fußballfilm angucken.
Ja, Überraschungen im Fußball gibt es vielleicht nur noch im Kinosaal oder vor dem Fernseher. Das wollen wir heute diskutieren im großen Tribünengespräch zum Thema Fußballfilme und Fußball im Film generell. Und damit Hallo und herzlich Willkommen hier im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Mein Name ist Max Ackob-Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und habe die große Ehre, dieses Gespräch hier zu moderieren mit zwei tollen Gästen. Deshalb begrüße ich bei mir jetzt gleich zum einen Ina Bargmann. Sie ist unter anderem in der Produktionsleitung beim 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival. Ina, ist das auch so dein Bezug zum Thema Fußballfilme?
Ja, spannend ist, dass der WM Gewinn 54 filmisch tatsächlich dann erst 50 Jahre später aufbereitet wurde. Also es gab natürlich viele Wochenmagazinberichte und ähnliches, also dokumentarische Darstellungen des Endspiels oder überhaupt der WM in der Schweiz, aber keine Filme sind daraus entstanden.
Was hältst du von der Theorie, dass das damit zusammenhängt, dass dieses Finale damals die Deutschen schon erlebt hatten, aber das sehr eng verknüpft war mit der Reportage von Herbert Zimmermann, mit der Radioreportage und deswegen sich lange kein Regisseur an eine filmische Umsetzung gewagt hat?
Ich glaube, dass die Reportage von Herbert Zimmermann so stark war, dass auch Sönke Wartmann nicht drumherum kam, die mit einzubauen. Herbert Zimmermann spielt dramaturgisch eine große Rolle in seinem Spielfilm, sodass man sich das sehr gut vorstellen kann. Aber es war eh nicht so einfach, die Leute damals eine visuelle Aufbereitung zu haben. Es gab ja noch wenige hunderttausend Menschen, die Fernsehbildschirme zu Hause hatten. Und ich glaube, dass diese Radioreportage auch eine Einmaligkeit hatte und nachklang. Von daher finde ich die These gar nicht abwegig.
Aber es ist ja auch oft so, dass eben dann so eine Auseinandersetzung dann nicht unmittelbar stattfindet, sondern eben viel später und auch eine neue Generation irgendwie dann das nochmal als interessant erachtet. Weil ein Dokumentarfilm ist natürlich was anderes, aber ein Spielfilm ist ja nochmal eine ganz neue Herangehensweise wieder an die Ereignisse, die da stattfanden.
Ja, vielleicht muss das auch so sein, damit diejenigen, die es damals noch live erlebt haben, das quasi wieder vergessen und der Spielfilm sich auch an ein Publikum richten kann, was zwar davon gehört hat, es aber zum ersten Mal dann in eigenen Bildern vor sich sieht. Also ich habe gerade zum Beispiel darüber nachgedacht, würde ich jetzt als Filmemacher die Abstiegskonferenz 99 mit Günther Koch in Nürnberg, bei dem Eintracht Frankfurt sich ja mit dem 5.1 rettet, würde ich das jetzt filmisch umsetzen, wo wir ja auch so eine herausragende Radio-Reportage haben. Und die Frage ist, könnte man jetzt dieses Ereignis, an das sich so viele aktuell noch erinnern, eigentlich ohne diese Radio-Reportage erzählen, oder müsste man da nicht einen ähnlichen Weg gehen wie beim Wunder von Bern? Und wahrscheinlich hängt das auch mit der kollektiven Erinnerung daran zusammen. Und dass die Leute das eben in den Ohren bzw. vor Augen haben, wie das damals gelaufen ist. Und deswegen wagt man sich da im direkten Nachgang zu so Ereignissen vielleicht als Filmemacher auch nicht so leicht ran.
Ich glaube, bei dem Spiel wäre es gar nicht möglich, weil man da diesen Satz hören würde. Das hat er sich doch ausgedacht. So unglaublich, dass man vielleicht da doch nostalgischer bleiben sollte und Günter Koch im Ohr behalten.
Das ja sowieso. Vor allem jetzt, wo sich zum 20. Mal Jährt und ja am 34. Spieltag der SC Freiburg auch den 1. FC Nürnberg zu Hause empfängt. Das wird vermutlich auch kein direkter Zuversand. Ich vermute, wir werden von dieser Reportage rund um diesen Mai-Termin dann noch einiges hören in diversen Fußballmedien. Aber jetzt haben wir ja einen großen Sprung gemacht. Wir waren ja eigentlich bei zwei Halbzeiten in der Hölle aus dem Jahr 1961. Birger, welcher Fußballfilm ist denn im Nachgang zu diesem Film noch aus deiner Sicht wichtig?
Ja, um über Dekaden zu sprechen, die 60er und Anfangs-70er spielten, da waren tatsächlich Spieler-Portraits die Filme, die für herausragende Ereignisse gesorgt haben. Einer heißt Garincha Allegria de Pozo, also wirklich über einen der wohl fünf besten Spieler aller Zeiten. Ich habe Ihnen das gestern noch gesagt, dass mein Opa immer schwer amüsiert berichtet hat, dass Garincha sowohl ein X als auch ein O-Bein hatte. Und dieses Portrait ist wirklich sehr gelungen, ist ein tolles Zeitgemälde, was die Fußballbegeisterung rund um die Spieler Garincha und Pelé angeht in den 60ern. Ein toller Schwarz-Weiß-Film und dann eben der vorhin schon genannte Fußball wie noch nie über George Best als Portrait 90-minütig bei seinem Spiel für Manchester United, damals gegen Coventry City. Das war dann alles so ein bisschen, also wo man sich heute auch noch überlegt, wer ist dafür ins Kino gegangen oder welche Kinos?
Ja, das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage gewesen, ja.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich die Frage und das waren wohl wirklich in erster Linie kleine Programmkinos in Großstädten, die sich vielleicht mal für eine Woche gewagt haben. Wir sind in der Recherche immer darauf gestoßen, dass, wenn dann die Filme tatsächlich auf einem Festival gelaufen sind, mit einer Ausstrahlung, kann man sagen, und dann später irgendwann mal als VHS-Kassette oder DVD auf den Markt gelandet sind.
Und jetzt war ja aber eine kurze Frage noch. Fußball wie noch nie war, so wie ich es jetzt hier lese, aber eine Produktion von einem deutschen Regisseur, Helmut Kostath.
Das war ein großer Film-Ästheten-Dokumentarfilmer, der zu der Zeit nicht dafür bekannt war, dass er Sportfilme gemacht hat. Es gab übrigens in der Zeit ein Sportfilmfestival in Oberhausen, das sogar mehrere Jahre bestand hatte, wo der Fußballfilm aber wirklich nur eine sehr geringe Rolle gespielt hat. Aber Helmut Kostath war eigentlich einer der wenigen Intellektuellen, du hast es vorhin über die 90er gesagt, und Anfang 2000 einer der wenigen Intellektuellen, der auch schon 1971 zu seiner Fußballliebe gestanden hat und die Möglichkeit hatte, best, der damals auch Popstar war, auf diese Art zu porträtieren.
Ja, aber es ist ja interessant, dass er sich keinen deutschen Spieler dafür ausgesucht hat, zeigt vielleicht dann auch die immer noch vorhandene Distanz zu den deutschen wichtigen Spielern. Da hat sich dann im Laufe der 70er einiges verändert.
Mit einem ziemlich gruseligen Film von Franz Beckenbauer, Libero 1973, wo er immer sagt, er schafft es nicht mehr, sich da ein paar Bilder anzugucken. Also es war wirklich wohl beschämend.
Also ein Spielfilm mit Franz Beckenbauer in der Hauptrolle, kann man sagen.
In der Hauptrolle, ja.
Über sich selbst, ja. Jedes Jahr diskutieren wir es wieder, ob wir mal die Reihe machen, Fußballer im Film. Aber wir haben immer so viele Einreichungen, dass es am Ende hinten rüberfällt. Aber irgendein Jahr müssen wir es mal schaffen, wirklich diese Reihe zu machen. Weil es gibt sehr viele Fußballer, die in Fußballfilmen, Spielfilmen auftreten. Als Fußballspieler, aber auch als ganz andere Personen.
Ihr könnt es ja verknüpfen mit dem Überthema Humor in Fußballfilmen, ungewollter, in Klammern, Humor in Fußballfilmen.
Aber der Libero ist bestimmt ein Leckerbissen. Der ist bis jetzt noch nicht bei uns gelaufen. So wie Ina das sagt, das ist wirklich eine Sache, die wir uns vornehmen. Geballter, da sind eben auch Filme dabei mit Paul Breitner in Potato Fist, Hadi Krüger und Ähnlichem.
Das ist natürlich auch interessant, dass das eher so die Filme sind, die in der breiten Masse Anklang finden, weil man sich darüber auch so gerne amüsieren kann. Viele von den Filmen, die du jetzt genannt hast, habe ich noch nicht gesehen, habe ich noch nichts von gehört. Lieberow habe ich jetzt gesehen und habe auch direkt wieder Erinnerungen daran, was ich da besonders lustig fand an diesem Film. Das sagt natürlich auch einiges aus, was beim Publikum dann verfängt und welche Filme es vielleicht etwas schwieriger haben, auch wenn sie viel besser gemacht sind.
Aber es ist auch eine absolute Rarität. Wie, wenn Schwarzenbeck kommt? Der Film ist von Werner Encke, der nicht Schummel-Liebling gedreht hat Ende der 60er. Das tolle ist, dass Katja Schwarzenbeck, Vorstopper der WM-Mannschaft 1974, selbst mit spielt in dem Film als Postbote und auch die einzige und letzte Szene des Films hat. Er trägt nämlich einen Brief aus und der ganze Film heißt, wie, wenn Schwarzenbeck kommt. Also es ist schon wirklich großartig, wie manche Regisseure dann eben auch ihre Fußballbegeisterung zumindest ein bisschen unterbringen können.
Aber das heißt, der Fußball spielt darüber hinaus keine Rolle in diesem Film?
Der spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. Und ich denke, wenn da Fußballfans drin gelandet sind, um den Schwarzenbeck zu sehen, die dann äußerst enttäuscht gewesen sind, zumindest 89 Minuten lang.
Ja gut, das ist ja wie die Angst des Tormanns beim FM. Da wurde ja auch tatsächlich verfilmt 1971. Das ist ja ganz ähnlich. Da geht es ja auch nicht um den Tormann eigentlich.
Hast du ihn gesehen damals?
Den Film habe ich nicht gesehen, aber weil ich auch meine Probleme mit der Rezeption des Buches hatte, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, also der Film beginnt mit einer Fußballszene. Das ist eigentlich genau umgekehrt zu dem, was ich eben gerade gesagt habe. Also die ersten zwei Minuten sind dort Fußball zu sehen und dann spielt es auch.
Genau, und der Buch ist ja genau umgedreht. Da geht es die ersten, was weiß ich wie viele Seiten, gar nicht um Fußball. Und ganz am Schluss kommt ein Fußballmotiv, das ist dann auch titelgebend. Und daraufhin haben alle, viele auch, die da gar nicht reingeguckt haben, in das Buch dann immer geglaubt. Das wäre das erste richtig literarische Werk aus dem deutschsprachigen Raum, was sich mit Fußball befasst. Aber wir wollen ja nicht über die Seitenstränge des Fußballfilms sprechen, sondern über die Hauptadern. Wen würdest du denn nach dem Libero, diesem unvergessenen Meister, weisen?
Da würde ich schon sagen, dass ein Film, der wirklich für Furore gesorgt hat zu der Zeit, unbedingt genannt werden muss, von John Huston Fluchte oder Sieg, ein sehr umstrittener Film Escape to Victory im Original. Dort hat John Huston es nämlich geschafft, mehrere Fußballer unterzubringen. Das waren Pelé, Bobby Moore, Adilis und Dana, der hervorragende polnische Spieler, haben mitgespielt. Es ist eine ähnliche Geschichte wie bei Zwei Halbzeit in der Hölle, dass Spieler versuchen, über ein Fußballspiel den Ausbruch zu starten aus einem deutschen Lager. Und es sind natürlich barbarische Ereignisse, die drum herum eine große Rolle spielen. Und umso grotesker ist eigentlich dieses Fußballspiel, das da mittendrin stattfindet, hat tatsächlich eine halbe Stunde Platz in dem Film. Auch Sylvester Stallone spielt beispielsweise den Torwart des gefangenen Teams. Und es lohnt sich, den Film zu gucken, aber man hat trotzdem ständig einen Zwiespalt in der Kritik. Also um zu sehen, wie das Ganze umgesetzt wurde. Es ist wirklich eine große Hollywood-Produktion, die auch ziemlich erfolgreich war.
Aus dem Jahr 1981, also wir sind jetzt schon in den 80ern tatsächlich. Als zwei Marksteine der Fußballfilmgeschichte – das ist ja schon interessant – haben wir einmal eben zwei Halbzeiten in der Hölle von 1961. Und 20 Jahre später nennst du mir als einen weiteren wichtigen Film der Film, der darauf basiert, der sich relativ eng daran orientiert hat. Und dann eben mit dieser völlig irren Star-Besetzung, mit Sylvester Stallone, Pelé und anderen bekannten Menschen, das nochmal anders aufarbeitet, aber nicht ganz unkritisch zu sehen ist.
Das ist auch das letzte Mal für eine lange Zeit, dass ein Spielfilm da noch eine Rolle spielt. Es gibt noch eine ganz wunderbare Jugendkomödie, die heißt Gregory's Girl, aus dem Jahr 1981 von Bill Forsythe, die z.B. Michael Kölmöhl, der Fußballunternehmer, der bei mehreren Vereinen ja geldgebend tätig war, und Weltkino-Betreiber des Kinounternehmen Leipzig, hat immer gesagt, das wäre für ihn der Grund gewesen, ins Filmgeschäft zu gehen. Der ist auch sehr lohnenswert, spielt in Schottland, ist eine kleine Liebesgeschichte, wo der Junge daran verzweifelt, dass das Mädchen besser Fußball spielt als er.
Das ist natürlich schlimm. Das ist ja ganz fürchterlich. Aber es ist ja auch ganz interessant, dass wir hier jetzt so langsam, zumindest bei den Beispielen, die wir uns jetzt hier herauspicken, dann auch einen Shift in der Themengebung sehen. Also wir sprechen zum einen, haben wir zwei große Filme, wo es darum geht, mit sportlichen Mitteln sollen Nazis besiegt oder nicht besiegt werden. Und das wird dann unterschiedlich interpretiert. Und jetzt haben wir aber aus dem gleichen Jahr wie Flucht oder Sieg eben diesen Film, den ich nicht gesehen habe, aber wo ich jetzt nach deiner Schilderung glaube, zu erkennen, da spielt der Fußball zwar eine motivgebende Rolle, aber eigentlich haben wir das, was du mir Ende der 20er so beschrieben hast, dass eine Liebesgeschichte im Fußballkontext stattfindet.
Jetzt hätte ich fast den wichtigsten vergessen. Und zwar aus dem Jahr 1974, Fünften der Knirps. Das ist ein Film, der so oft wie kein anderer beim 11mm Filmfestival auch gezeigt wurde. Wurde auch gekürt zum besten Fußballspielfilm aller Zeiten. Wer ihn nicht kennen sollte, was bedauerlich genug wäre, wenn es Hörerinnen und Hörer gibt deines Podcasts, die den Film noch nicht kennen.
Du sprichst sogar mit jemandem, der ihn noch nicht kennt. Ich schäme mich jetzt schon.
Das ist ja ein Ding. Es geht um einen kleinen schwedischen Jungen, der in der Nationalmannschaft landet, weil er so hoch talentiert ist. Das Tolle ist, er ist sieben Jahre jung und muss mit dem Starrum klarkommen.
Und er landet aber in der Männernationalmannschaft.
Das Tolle ist, dass es wirklich die originelle schwedische Nationalmannschaft ist, die sich in der Zeit für die WM 74 qualifizieren musste. Die Drehaufnahmen, die rund um diesen Spielfilm stattgefunden haben, standen immer in Zusammenhang mit den Qualifikationsspielen der schwedischen Nationalmannschaft. Das heißt, sie haben sich tatsächlich bereit erklärt, sich für die Filmaufnahmen aufzustellen, um dann hinterher ihre tatsächlichen Qualifikationsspiele zu spielen. Das war sehr erfolgreich. Schweden hat es dann auch geschafft zur WM 74 nach Deutschland. Der Film ist wirklich zauberhaft, weil die Spielszenen sind überaus amüsant gestaltet, wenn er dann beispielsweise die Abwehrreihe der russischen Mannschaft austanzt.
Die Gegner waren dann aber Statisten. Das waren jetzt nicht auch die wirklichen.
Die Gegner waren Statisten. Das haben sie nicht mit sich machen lassen. Aber das Tolle ist, so wie man das aus schwedischen Kinderfilmen kennt, dann doch auch eine sehr emanzimatorische Art und Weise, was Kinder machen dürfen. Und er kann eben auch den Schulunterricht schwänzen bzw. schläft ein in der Schule, weil er so viele Fußballtrainingen hat oder lange Reisen hinter sich. Und dann, um zum Schluss für sich zu entscheiden, ist es einfach toller, ein Kinderleben zu führen als ein Fußballstar zu sein und wieder mit den alten Kumpels zu spielen. Das ist ganz hervorragend. Der Junge ist später LKW-Fahrer geworden. Den haben wir versucht einzuladen. Hat leider nicht geklappt. Aber es gibt immer wieder die Anfragen, ob der Film nicht wieder bei uns gezeigt werden kann oder wo man ihn bekommen könnte.
Und ist es dann auch ein Film, der sich auch an Kinder richtet?
Wie man so sagt, zwischen 1986 und 1986. Also jeder, der sich da reinsetzt, wird seinen Spaß haben.
Okay, faszinierend. Ich komme auf meinen Pile of Shame, dass ich den noch nicht gesehen habe. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja mal einen Filmnachmittag. Vielleicht auch noch mit zwei zusätzlichen Zuschauerinnen aus meinem Haushalt. Das hört sich tatsächlich spannend an. Und diese Rahmengeschichte, dass da die echte schwedische Nationalmannschaft im Rahmen ihrer tatsächlich stattfindenden Qualifikationsspiele vorher noch Dreharbeiten zugelassen hat, das ist natürlich der Wahnsinn. Das setzt dem Ganzen ja nochmal die Krone auf. Toll. Ich müsste euch da was schenken, dass ihr euch hier die Zeit nehmt. Zusätzlich ja noch zu – also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr seid gerade – keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich haben wir gerade die Stundenmarke passiert oder irgendwie so. Aber wir sind schon seit – meine Güte – jetzt fast drei Stunden hier schon am Ruck tun. Wir hatten noch ein paar technische Hickups im Vorfeld, im Zwischenfeld dieser Aufnahme. Also wenn, dann schulde ich euch etwas. Aber toll, dass ich jetzt auf jeden Fall weiß, was ich gucken kann. Und wenn das der Film ist, der bei euch auf dem Festival als bester Fußballfilm aller Zeiten ausgezeichnet wurde, dann muss das auch schnell jetzt geguckt werden. Das hört sich wirklich nach einem ganz bezaubernden Streifen an.
Ja, wir hatten ihn auch noch mal im Programm vor kurzem, weil es eine restaurierte Fassung jetzt gibt. Also es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall da rein zu gucken.
Fimpender Knirps, toll, aus dem Jahr 1974. Jetzt sind wir kurz zurückgesprungen, Birger, aus den 80ern in die Mitte der 70er. Wo würdest du gerne weitermachen? Was war für dich so das nächste Highlight?
Ich würde gerne weitermachen mit einem sogenannten Subgenre. Also es ist der Fanfilm, der natürlich auch eine Rolle spielt. Da gab es 1991 einen Film, der hieß Ultra. Das ist ein Film, der ein Wochenende zwei rivalisierende Fangruppen skizziert. Ich war früher als Fernsehzuschauer selten die Möglichkeit gehabt, Fußball in fiktionaler Form zu sehen. Das war ein Film, der mich wirklich umgehauen hat, aber negativ. Es sind Gewaltszenarien, die kaum aushaltbar waren. Ich hatte mich damals schon gewundert, dass da nicht erst ab 16 oder 18 freigegeben aufleuchtete, als der Film das erste Mal im Fernsehen gezeigt wurde.
Warte kurz, das würde mich noch interessieren. Es geht um ein Spiel zwischen AS. Rhoam und Juventus Turin und dann eben den gewalttätigen Auseinandersetzung zwischen Fans bei der Vereine. Basiert das auf Wahnereignissen, nimmt der Film für sich in Anspruch, einen Alltag in fiktiver Art zu beschreiben, den es so aber gibt? Oder wie hat sich der Film da positioniert? Weil wenn der so der Beginn dieser Filme ist – und ich weiß, dass da jetzt noch einige aus dieser Richtung kommen – würde mich das noch mal interessieren.
Ja, das ist so. Also er verzichtet eigentlich auf die Hintergründe. Er setzt komplett auf die Stärke der Authentizität, was die Fan-Auseinandersetzung angeht. Also es ist drum herum, welche Rolle die Vereine spielen oder so. Das wäre eigentlich auch auf viele andere internationale Fanszenen zu übertragen. Das Starke war an dem Film, dass er wirklich dann einige Leute, die in der Szene schon seit Jahren aktiv waren, wohl als Berater dabei waren, die Sprechchöre übersetzt haben. Es ist halt die Reise der Roma-Fans nach Turin, die dort eine Rolle spielt und dann die Auseinandersetzungen, die wirklich unmittelbar vor dem Spiel stattfinden. Es ist Stoff für Gewalt faszinierend, kann man sagen.
Okay, und dann bekommt er quasi seine Wucht daher, dass das zwar fiktive Personeneignisse sind, aber in einem Rahmen, der authentisch wirkt und es vielleicht auch in weiten Teilen ist. Und daher wirkt ja diese Brutalität nochmal anders. Deswegen habe ich eben gefragt, als wenn das jetzt etwas komplett ausgedachtes, brutales wäre, sondern dann hat das nochmal eine andere Wucht auf den Zuschauer und die Zuschauerin.
Das ist wirklich so, dass einige Filme sich rund um die Faszination Holigenismus aufbauen.
Kannst du mir erklären, warum? Warum ist das eigentlich so, dass uns Gewalt so sehr fasziniert, dass dann im Fußballfilm sah es eine Zeitlang sogar so aus, als wäre das das wichtigste Thema für Fußballfilme. Hat sich jetzt wieder ein bisschen verändert.
Doch, ich denke, Gewalt lässt sich ja immer gut verkaufen. Wenn wir uns jetzt aktuelle Fälle anschauen, wie die medial aufbereitet werden, sowohl in der Boulevard als auch in der seriösen Presse, ist ja schon so, dass Gewalterscheinungen rund um ein Fußballspiel tatsächlich auch dafür sorgen, dass diskutiert wird. Das ist wirklich, ich denke, auch so ein Hintergedanke gewesen, von Filmproduzenten zu sagen, Mensch, wir drehen diesen Film nicht nur für Leute, die in der Ultra- oder Hooligan-Szene sind, die sich den Film tatsächlich dann auch angucken. Das habe ich an einem ganz für mich irren Beispiel feststellen können, als wir 2004, zwei Jahre vor der WM, den Film Football Factory gezeigt haben, britische Fans und verschiedene Fan-Gruppen aus Berlin eingeladen haben, also sowohl von Union als auch von Hertha, als auch von BFC, Dynamo und TV-Fans. Es waren 200 Leute in einem Kinosaal und der Veranstalter, das war damals der British Council, gesagt, Mensch, können wir das überhaupt machen und wie viel Securitypersonal gibt es? Und wir haben das Ganze gemeinsam mit dem Fanprojekt gemacht und eben gesagt, ne, das geht schon gut, also wenn man zu dem Thema was Gemeinsames hat und hinterher eine Diskussion dazu führt, dann kann das ein erfolgreicher Abend werden. Und genauso war es dann, also wir hatten englische Fans vor Ort, die über den Film gesprochen haben. Auch dort gab es Leute, die beratend für die Filmemacher unterwegs waren und die Berliner Fans, egal welcher Couleur haben, haben hinterher sich sehr stark engagiert bei der Anschlussdiskussion. Also das ist schon ein Stoff, der erstmal Leute aus der Szene selbst fasziniert. Aber ich glaube auch, dass so ein gewisser Gewaltkick auch Cineasten berühren kann. Also nicht umsonst gibt es Filme mit starken Gewalt aus einer Andersetzung, die hohe Zuschauerzahlen haben.
Und Football Factory, aus welchem Jahr ist der nochmal? Das ist ja einer der bekanntesten Fußballfilme tatsächlich.
Ja, Football Factory ist aus dem Jahr 2004 Regie Nick Lowe.
Und was ist dazwischen passiert? Weil du hast ja schon gesagt, wir bewegen uns jetzt in diesem Subgenre des Fanfilms.
Ja, nicht nur des Fanfilms, sondern verschiedene Subgenres spielt eine Rolle. Also tatsächlich gab es, so wie man es in anderen Bereichen kennt, eine Menge Trash-Filme, die eigentlich gar nicht so genannt werden sollen. Aber das hat Ina am Anfang schon gesagt, es gibt eigentlich nichts, was es nicht gibt im Bereich. Fußballfilme von Komödie über Thriller zu Splatter. Es gibt Pornos, die eine Rolle spielen im Fußballbereich. Also das ist schon sehr weit gefächert. Und gerade in der Zeit ist man sehr erfolgreich, wenn man auf der Suche nach Trash-Filmen ist. Die 80er-Jahre haben auch dafür zu beigetragen, dass der Fußballfilm nicht so einen guten Ruf hat. Also beispielsweise Wundefußballfilme. Davon gibt es eine ganze Menge. Kung-Fu-Fußballfilme. Also das ist wirklich schon bizarr, was da alles zu entdecken ist.
Ja, man muss sich einiges antun, um die Perlen rauszufiltern.
Da bin ich ja froh, dass ich euch habe, dass ich mich nur auf die Perlen stürzen kann. Was ist denn dann so die nächste Perle? Also wir standen ja eigentlich im Jahr 1991 mit ultra blutiger Sonntag, wo du ja auch sehr eindrücklich dein biografisches Erlebnis dazu beschrieben hast, Birger. Was ist denn in dieser Phase noch wichtig an Fußballfilmen?
Da gibt es den zweiten Kinderklassiker, Le Ballon d'Or. Wir schmunzeln immer so ein bisschen bei den Einreichungen Jahr für Jahr, dass ein Themenbereich tatsächlich am stärksten bearbeitet wird inzwischen. Das ist ein junger, talentierter, afrikanischer Spieler, der versucht, auf dem europäischen Fußballmarkt Fuß zu fassen. Er wird meist sowohl ins Spielfilm als auch im Dokumentarfilm von Spielerberatern ausgenutzt. Nach kurzen, harten Monaten in Europa muss er wieder zurück nach Afrika. Die ganze Enttäuschung und auch diese ganze Brutalität, die dieser Spielermarkt-Business mit sich bringt, wird dargestellt. Und da gibt es verschiedene Einreichungen, die wir Jahr für Jahr sichten. Auch einige davon qualitativ gut, die wir gezeigt haben. Und der Ballon d'Or, da handelt es sich tatsächlich in einem Film von 1994 zum ersten Mal um diese Thematik. Ein Film, der aber von ganz hervorragenden Darstellern lebt. Und er war auch von der Geschichtserzählung ziemlich einmalig zu der Zeit. Dann 1997 – Fever Pitch – haben wir schon darüber gesprochen. Eine wunderbare Komödie mit dem sehr bekannten Colin Furze in der Hauptrolle. Auch das ist ziemlich selten, dass große Schauspieler und Schauspielerinnen sich in einen Fußballfilm wagen. In den 20er- 30er- 40er-Jahren war das schon eher üblich. Aber in der jetzigen Zeit und in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten war das nicht so stark.
Das hängt vielleicht auch damit zusammen, dass das Buch sehr erfolgreich war. Den Film habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht gesehen, muss ich jetzt mal gestehen. Die DVD kannst du mir dann mal schenken. Aber ich habe das Buch gelesen, aber den Film habe ich nie gesehen.
Mich hat da schon der deutsche Titel Ballfieber ein bisschen angestoßen.
Ja, deutsche Titel muss man einfach ignorieren.
Vielleicht wirklich. Aber hatte der damals auch an den Kinokassen großen Erfolg?
Ja, er hatte Erfolg. Er hatte keinen großen Erfolg, aber er hatte Erfolg. Er hatte mehrere hunderttausend Zuschauer in Großbritannien. Und er ist in Deutschland auf dem DVD-Markt ziemlich gut gelaufen.
Okay, interessant. Also da hat sich dann nach dem Buch, was ja auch so breitere Massen erreicht hat, auch der Film nochmal einen ähnlichen Weg eingeschlagen. Und du würdest sagen, er ist auch gut anzusehen, wenn man das Buch kennt. Wenn man das Buch nicht kennt, ist ein guter Umgang mit diesem Thema Fußball im Film.
Also eigentlich ist es der ideale Film, um Menschen zum ersten Mal einen Fußballfilm sehen zu lassen. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich durch die Romantik des Films, durch die Heiterkeit möglich einzusteigen und zu sagen, ah, so sind Fußballfans ja auch. Er ist ja Lehrer in seinem Beruf und wie er dann eben seinen Alltag an der Schule verbringt, aber auch wie er sich dann wandelt, also sein zweites Leben führt, sobald er mit seinem besten Kumpel zusammen im Wohnzimmer sitzt und sich Spiele anguckt oder auch im Stadion.
Also ein Einblick in die Feldziele. Ok, und man kann dadurch selbst verstanden werden, wenn man selbst Fußballfan ist, wenn man anderen Leuten diesen Film zeigt. Das nehme ich jetzt daraus mit. Sehr gut, den muss ich auf meine Visitenkarte drucken, diesen Film.
Ja, da kommt das wichtigste Mannschaftsportrait, das bis heute gedreht worden ist. Obwohl ich auch mit Vergnügen des Sommermärchen geguckt habe, 2006, das ist ja so ein bisschen ein umstrittener Film, aber den müsste ich mir tatsächlich mal wieder angucken. Aber mir hat er damals Spaß gemacht. Und das ist ein sehr interessantes Thema, ist Les yeux d'honnebleu von Stefan Meunier wirklich ein herausragendes Beispiel, wie man eine Equipe begleiten kann. Das ist wirklich zur WM 1998 gewesen, also die ganze Zeit, die ganze Begeisterung rum, und die französische Nationalmannschaft spielt eine Rolle. Aber auch die Spieler selbst werden hervorragend angesprochen, also sensibel begleitet mit der Kamera. Und trotzdem hat man das Gefühl, dass man in den vier Wochen ganz eng dabei war. Und ja, das ist sehr lohnenswert. Das war für uns einer der ersten richtig großen Höhepunkte, weil wir im zweiten Festivaljahr den Regisseur vor Ort hatten. Eine Sache, die wir uns damals wirklich noch gar nicht vorstellen können, dass solche Leute dann auch mal nach Berlin kommen, unser Festival zu besuchen.
Und wenn ich es gerade richtig sehe, dann ist es nach Garincha, den du vorhin erwähnt hast, der ja im Jahr 1962 rausgekommen ist, jetzt die erste Dokumentation, die jetzt wieder hier im Rahmen der Filme, die wir besprochen haben, stattfindet.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ganz enorm. Also die zehn besten Dokumentarfilme, um nochmal auf dieses Ranking einzugehen, die gewählt worden sind, da ist er tatsächlich der Älteste, erstaunlicherweise. Also die ganzen Dokumentarfilme, die wir als herausragend erachten, sind zwischen 2002 und 2017 entstanden. Also das ist schon ganz erstaunlich.
Ja, in der Phase, in der der Fußball immer mehr zu einer eigenen Welt wurde, in die man von außen nicht mehr so gut reingucken konnte. Vielleicht hat das damit einfach zu tun, dass einen dann deswegen das dann auch so fasziniert und gleichzeitig Dokumentarfilme nochmal einen anderen Ansatzpunkt haben, weil sie eben einen Einblick erlauben, den man sonst nicht hat.
Ja, tatsächlich war das der allererste Fußballfilm, den ich gesehen habe. Es war damals in Frankreich. Ich habe ihn mit einer französischen Synchronisation gesehen. Und ich war tatsächlich total geflasht, dass überhaupt Fußball im Kino vorkommt und dass auch eine Frau Fußball spielt. Generell auf der großen Leinwand auch noch gut Fußball spielt. Ich habe den Film jetzt tatsächlich nochmal gesehen, vor ein paar Tagen in Vorbereitung hier auf diese Sendung. Er hat mir immer noch ganz gut gefallen. Ich muss sagen, ich fand ihn so ein bisschen trashig im Nachgang. Vielleicht kurz etwas zum Inhalt des Films. Es geht um ein Mädchen, die in England groß wird mit indischen Eltern, die ihr das Fußballspielen verbieten. Sie befreundet sich eben mit einer Engländerin an. Die zwei gehen zusammen zu einer Mannschaft und spielen dann recht erfolgreich. Es kommt ein amerikanischer Talentscout, die Liebe spielt natürlich auch noch eine Rolle. Es waren eben zwei Frauen. Für mich war es wirklich ein Schlüsselerlebnis, gut Fußballspielende Frauen auf der Leinwand zu sehen und überhaupt Fußball auf der Leinwand zu sehen. Das war für mich das erste Mal, dass diese Leidenschaft für Fußball mit der Leidenschaft für Kino zusammenkam.
Das war ja auch damals ein sehr bekannter Film. Nicht nur durch die Referenz an David Beckham, der halt rund um die Jahrtausendwende einer der Fußballstars war. Der hatte ja auch wirklich einen großen Anklang im Publikum, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ja, ich habe auch gestern tatsächlich noch mal so ein bisschen recherchiert. Also der hat, glaube ich, wahnsinnig gut eingespielt weltweit. Also einer der am meisten besuchtesten Kinofilme zum Thema Fußball bis jetzt immer noch. Also hat mit die meisten Einnahmen eingespielt. Und natürlich Keira Knightley hat danach natürlich auch eine steile Karriere hingelegt. Die spielte die Freundin.
Und du hast jetzt gerade schon angedeutet, du hast den Film jetzt noch mal im Jahr 2019 angeguckt. Der ist ja jetzt schon 17 Jahre alt. Du hast gesagt, in einigen Stellen kam er dir ein bisschen trashig vor. Aber findest du, das Thema Fußball wird da auch auf eine nachhaltige Art und Weise bearbeitet, sodass es sich auch lohnt, ihn jetzt noch anzugucken?
Total. Also ich wollte jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass der Film nicht gut ist, sondern ich war so begeistert davon damals und hatte ihn auch so in meiner Erinnerung. Und so ist es ja manchmal, wenn man dann nochmal was anschaut, Jahre später. Also ich fand, dass es zum Teil echt nicht so gut gespielt war. Also jetzt nicht von den Hauptdarstellerinnen, aber gerade so von Nebendarstellern und Darstellerinnen, dass es so ein bisschen übertrieben gespielt ist einfach. Aber es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall. Und das ist auch ein Film, wo eben natürlich der Fußball gut eingebaut wird sozusagen. Weil eben der Fußball ist für die Protagonistin in dem Film eben einfach ein Mittel, sich zu befreien von ihrer Familie anzukommen in der englischen Gesellschaft. Und das wird total gut umgesetzt. Also lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, den zu gucken.
Ich finde das ganz wichtig, dass ihr jetzt nochmal gesagt habt, wie alt der Film auch schon ist. Inna, machst du gleich noch was dazu sagen, dass wir auch ein eigenes Kinder- und Jugendfilmfestival haben. Und wir fragen uns dann immer, ist der nicht schon zu oft gezeigt worden? Aber wenn man heute mal 10- 12- 14-jährige Mädchen und Jungs fragen würde, kennt ihr Kick It Like Beckham, würde man wahrscheinlich in Fragen der Augen gucken. Ich denke, es lohnt sich immer wieder, solche Filme neu wieder darzustellen.
Ja klar, gerade beim Kinder- und Jugendfestival ist es ja auch nochmal was anderes als beim Erwachsenen 11mm, beim großen 11mm-Festival, wo wir wirklich wahnsinnig viele neue Filme eingereicht bekommen jedes Jahr oder recherchieren. Beim Kinder- und Jugendfestival 11mm findet im September statt, auch hier in Berlin. Da fokussieren wir uns tatsächlich oft auf Filme, die auch schon mal gelaufen sind, weil es einfach gar nicht so viele Neuerscheinungen gibt und da wäre natürlich eigentlich es gut, so einen Film nochmal reinzunehmen.
Sehr gut, dann haben wir hier live und eher schon mal ein kleines Mosaiksteinchen des Minimeter-Programms geklärt. Das ist doch schön zu wissen. Wenn wir jetzt im Jahr 2002 sind, bei Kick It Like Backcam, dann sehe ich, dass da auch ein Die Helden von Bern-Film erschienen ist, der ein Animationsfilm war und das ist nicht das Wunder von Bern, der im Jahr darauf erschienen ist. Birger, darauf habe ich euch jetzt nicht vorbereitet, es ist jetzt eine Frage aus dem Blauen heraus. Aber kannst du mir zu diesem Film was erzählen, von dem hatte ich vorher noch nie was gehört?
Ja, das ist – wie heißt die Technik noch? Trick and Stop-Motion. Das sind Lego-Spieler, die tatsächlich das Spiel nachspielen. Mit dem Originalton von Herbert Zimmermann werden die fünf Tore gezeigt. Der prasselnde Regen spielt eine Rolle im Bankdorfstadion. Das ist eine ganz hervorragende Animation. Der Film macht viel Spaß.
Sehr gut. Was ist denn der nächste Langfilm, also ein Film mit längerer Laufzeit, der in euren Augen bedeutend ist?
In der ersten zweitausender Hälfte – wir haben über das Wunder von Bern selbst schon gesprochen – kam die bis jetzt größte Produktion aller Spielfilme auf den Markt Goal. Eine US-Produktion, Regisseur Danny Cannon, und zwar gleich als Trilogie. Das ist eine klassische Aufsteigergeschichte, hat viel Ähnlichkeit zu Rocky. Rocky Balboa heißt Santo Munez und transferiert wird aus einem latinamerikanischen Land hin nach Newcastle, dort bei Newcastle United spielt, und dann in Teil 2 oder 3, so weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr genau, dann seinen Weg weitermacht und nach Real Madrid geht. Der ist für ein sehr breites Publikum gemacht, auch hier eine dramatische Liebesgeschichte im Hintergrund, aber es geht auch um Drogenkonsum im Fußballbereich, es geht um Korruption, um gute und schlechte Deals, aber was der Film hat, oder alle drei Filme, ist eine wahnsinnig gute Kameratechnik.
Spannend. Es gibt auch viele Cameo-Auftritte, lese ich von David Beckham über Zidane, Raoul, Alan Shearer, da könnte man beliebig weitergehen. Da sieht man aber schon die Größe der Produktion von damals, und vielleicht hat das ja auch die eine oder andere Hörerin und der eine oder andere Hörer schon mitbekommen, selbst wenn er oder sie den Film nicht gesehen hat, gerade als damals der erste Teil veröffentlicht wurde. Das war im Jahr 2005 schon ein ganz schön großes Thema.
Dann möchte ich einen Film platzieren, den kennt niemand, aber es ist einer meiner Lieblingsfußballfilme. Der Film heißt Das Jahr, als meine Eltern im Urlaub waren. Er kommt aus Brasilien, aus dem Jahr 2006, ist wiederum ein Spielfilm. Die Geschichte dreht sich um einen kleinen Jungen, zehn Jahre alt, das Ganze spielt zur WM 1970 in Mexiko. Er ist Brasilianer, naturgemäß eben auch großer Fan der brasilianischen Nationalmannschaft. Seine Eltern sind Kommunisten, die in der Zeit der brasilianischen Militärdiktatur verfolgt und verhaftet werden. Das ist die Parallelgeschichte dazu, wenn der Junge am Fernsehschirm klebt und sich wohnt, wo seine Eltern geblieben sind und ihm gesagt wird, sie sind in den Urlaub gefahren. Dann bleibt er zu Hause bei seinem Großvater und guckt zusammen mit einer Gruppe von Studenten in einer Kneipe zusammen die brasilianischen Spiele. Das ist wahnsinnig anrührend. Wir haben vorhin schon über das Todesspiel in Kiev gesprochen, aber das ist ein weiteres Beispiel dafür, wie Fußball, Film und Politik zusammengebracht werden. Das ist ein Schwerpunkt, den wir letztes Jahr vielleicht in der Maxi noch etwas dazu sagen. Fußball, Film und Macht ist letztes Jahr unsere Überschrift des Jahresschwerpunktes.
Genau, wir haben zusammen mit der Kooperative Berlin, das sind Medienschaffende im weitesten Sinne. Die machen Podcasts, Filme zu politischen Themen. Auch mit denen zusammen haben wir einen Schwerpunkt gestrickt. Fußball und Macht, wo es eben um das Zusammenspiel von Fußball und Politik und Fußball und Macht auch ging. Zum Beispiel auch unser Eröffnungsfilm vom letzten Jahr, The Workers Cup, der sich mit dem Bau der WM-Stadion in Katar beschäftigt, bzw. viel mehr mit den Arbeitern, die da beteiligt sind und die wiederum sich so ein eigenes Fußballturnier organisieren. Aber es geht natürlich viel um die Arbeitsbedingungen, um die Lebensbedingungen der Menschen dort. Und wir haben zusammen mit der Kooperative dann auch eine Podcastreihe gemacht. Aber die waren ja auch bei dir zu Gast schon im Rasenfunk.
Genau, aber wir können sehr gerne nochmal auf sie hinbeisen.
Fußball macht sehr viel. Genau, die haben eben Gesprächsrunden zu den verschiedenen Filmen geführt, die alle auch noch online verfügbar sind.
Sehr spannendes Thema, Fußballpolitik.
Auf jeden Fall. Und nicht endend. Wir haben auch in diesem Jahr wieder einige Produktionen zu dem Thema, die herausragend sind. 2008 ist das Jahr zweier toller Dokumentarfilme. Ein ganz großer und ein ganz kleiner. Die Hand Gottes, Maradona, Paa Kusturica. Eine Huldigung und Liebeserklärung, die fast ein bisschen zu fett ist. Vom Regisseur Emil Kusturica fehlt vielleicht auch der kritische Blick auf den Protagonisten Diego Maradona. Aber es ist ja wirklich so eine Schildernde-Gestalt, dass man fasziniert ist, also zu sehen, was seine Anhänger und Anhängerinnen für einen Kult rund um ihn betreiben. Aber eben auch, er hat da schon nicht mehr seine beste Zeit. Es steht schwer übergewichtig als Interviewpartner zur Verfügung und blickt gemeinsam mit dem Regisseur auf die Höhepunkte seines Lebens und auch seines Fußballerlebens natürlich zurück. Es ist ein Film zum Eintauchen und hat viele Menschen begeistert. Er hat bei uns das Festival gewonnen und Imme Kostorica hat tatsächlich auch unseren Pokal, die Goldene Elf, bei sich zu Hause zu stehen.
Das ist doch schön. Dann hat er neben Maradona, ist er jetzt hoffentlich noch Fan des 11mm-Fußballfilmfestivals. Das ist die dicke Dokumentation, was ist die unbekannte?
Die andere Dokumentation ist in Berlin weltbekannt, aber ansonsten darüber hinaus wohl eher nicht. Das ist Football Undercover, ein Film über ein Länderspiel Kreuzberg gegen Iran. Also junge Frauen aus Kreuzberg, die hier im Spielbetrieb waren und in der Bezirksliga gespielt haben, hatten die Idee und interkulturell aufgestellt sind. Ich glaube, 16 Spielerinnen aus neun Nationen hatten die Idee, ein Spiel mit einer iranischen Mannschaft auszutragen. Das Ganze wurde geleitet. Die Idee entstand durch zwei Zwillinge, die dort in der Mannschaft gespielt haben, die dann zugleich für Regie und Schnitt des Films zuständig waren, Marlene und Valerie Aßmann. Die es geschafft haben, bei allen diplomatischen Schwierigkeiten ein Freundschaftsspiel in Teheran auszutragen. Das Tolle ist, man kann diese Mannschaft auf dieser Reise begleiten und man darf da hinblicken, wo sonst niemand hinblicken darf, weil es beispielsweise den iranischen Männern komplett verboten war, das Spiel zu begleiten, also dazu zu gucken, aber man geht auch zu den Spielerinnen nach Hause und bekommt ganz viel vom iranischen Privatleben mit. Es ist ein Herzensprojekt gewesen und ein Film, der uns alle damals sehr begeistert hat. Ja, dann kommen wir eigentlich schon in die Zehnerjahre. Wieder ein Film, der es geschafft hat, sehr bekannt zu werden, war Looking for Eric. Es liegt natürlich daran, dass einerseits Eric tatsächlich Eric Cantona war, als Nebendarsteller, aber gleichzeitig mit einer ungeheuren wichtigen Funktion in dem Film, um einem gescheiterten Arbeiter und unglücklichen Fußballfan viel Selbstbewusstsein zu geben, Empowerment zu geben, taucht Eric Cantona als Figur auf, die eigentlich imaginär ist, aber für den Protagonisten eine große Rolle spielt. Ken Loach ist ein Mann, der komplett Fußball begeistert ist, er ist einer der wichtigsten Regisseure der letzten Jahrzehnte, kann man sagen, europäischen Regisseure, meist mit sozialkritischen Themen. Er hat in der Tat fünf Fußballfilme gedreht. Wir versuchen, Jahr für Jahr ihn für eine Hommage zu gewinnen. Mittlerweile ist er 83 und auch nicht mehr so reisefreudig. Aber er weiß von dem Festival und ich glaube, das wäre so etwas wie der Schirmherr für das Ganze. Ein erfolgreicher Spielfilm, der auch in Deutschland über 100.000 Zuschauer hatte, das ist schon eine ganze Menge und in Großbritannien sehr erfolgreich war. 2009, der wohl neben Film der Knirps beste Fußballspielfilm, so ist er ebenfalls bei uns gewertet worden, auf Platz zwei gelandet, damals The Damned United über den Trainer Brian Clubs, das habe ich vorher schon kurz angesprochen. Und dann gibt es wiederum eine Dokumentation, die wir noch sehr empfehlen können, The Other Chelsea heißt der Mann, ein Berliner Filmemacher, der über einen Oligarchen aus der Ukraine berichtet in diesem Dokumentarfilm. Und ja, rund um Schachtjoa Donets zwei Spielzeiten des Vereins begleitet und inzwischen schon weit, weit zurück liegt, weil es damals noch in der friedlichen Ukraine stattgefunden hat. Ja, überaus gelungen.
Und das heißt, The Damned United blickt ja zurück und ist dann ein Spielfilm und das andere ist jetzt eine Dokumentation oder?
Ja, das ist eine Dokumentation.
Okay, spannend zu hören. Und ab jetzt werden es richtig viele Filme langsam, die man so pro Jahr sichten kann, oder?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Man kann sagen, das Jahr 2010, wenn man so zurückguckt, war das erste Jahr, wo wir es geschafft haben, das Festival, oder hätten es machen können, wollen wir mal so in der Form sprechen, nur von Einreichungen das Festival zu gestalten. Vorher mussten wir selbst immer recherchieren, beziehungsweise so schön, wie du unterstützt wirst, wurden auch wir immer unterstützt von Menschen, die irgendwo auf der Welt einen Fußballfilm gesehen haben und gesagt haben, Mensch, wäre das nicht was für euch, und uns den Tipp geschickt haben, wir mussten dann gucken, wer ist der Filmverleiher dazu, die Produktion. Aber seitdem, so wie Ina das vorhin gesagt hat, wir sind jetzt bei 250 eingereichten Filme gelandet, und das ist schon auch was Tolles, wenn man die Qual der Wahl hat, um so ein Filmprogramm zusammenzustellen.
Und ist ja auch so ein bisschen dann stellvertretend, also ihr seid ja dann mit eurem Festival der Seismograf dafür, welche Rolle Fußball im Film spielt. Und dann können wir eben so 2010 als die Marke ansetzen, wo man sagen kann, okay, ab jetzt wird es richtig viel, der Output ist sehr groß, es gibt ein reichhaltigeres Angebot als in den Jahren davor. Es wurde eben immer mehr. Und welche Filme würdet ihr dann gerne herausheben wollen ab 2010? Jetzt wird es ja dann richtig schwierig. Vorher war es ja einfach, wenn wir über 1927 sprechen, ja, das waren halt auch die wenigen Filme, die jetzt noch bekannt sind, die sich damals mit dem Thema Fußball auseinandergesetzt haben. Jetzt dürfte es ja schon kniffliger werden, einige herauszugreifen.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Also da kommen wirklich so die persönlichen Highlights dann dazu. Also Filme, mit denen man rund um das Festival besondere Erinnerungen hat, wo ich jetzt gar nicht mehr sagen würde, das war der Film des Jahres oder so, weil er qualitativ so herausragend war. Aber ein Highlight war auf jeden Fall ein Amateurfilm, nämlich der Film von Sepp Maier über die WM 1990. Also Sepp Maier hat damals als Torwarttrainer eine Kamera dabei gehabt und hat die spätere Weltmeistermannschaft begleitet und hat dieses Videomaterial bei sich zu Hause gehabt. Und dann passiert wirklich die unglaubliche Geschichte, dass ich all meinen Mut zusammengenommen habe, bei ihm angerufen habe und gefragt habe, ob es nicht möglich wäre, diesen Film im Kino zu zeigen. Ob es denn überhaupt ein richtiger Film wäre. Und dann ist er mit mir am Telefon in der Hand durch seine Wohnstube und urig kommentiert, was er alles schon so gemacht hat. Er hat gesagt, ja, hier stehen sie ja, die können es haben. Und dann haben wir eben von ihm alle Rechte bekommen, diese Filmaufnahmen zu zeigen. Und das war wirklich ein absoluter Hype, der dann stattgefunden hat. Weil das Kino war mehrfach ausverkauft, weil so viele Leute diesen Film sehen wollten. Sepp Maier ist selbst gekommen, viele Kollegen aus dem Profi-Fußball waren da zu Gast. Herbert Zimmermann haben wir als Moderator gewinnen können für den Abend. Und das ist natürlich eine Sache, wo ich jetzt immer noch sagen würde, gut, das war nicht der beste Fußballfilm der letzten zehn Jahre. Aber das war ein unglaubliches Ereignis.
Aber er ist nirgendwo erschienen. Also das sind weiter Privataufnahmen von ihm und den kann man jetzt nicht nachträglich noch irgendwo sehen.
Nee, der ist nicht erschienen, weil die rechte Lage so schräg ist. Also man müsste eigentlich jeden einzelnen Spieler fragen, ob er in dem Film gezeigt werden darf. Und Sepp Maier war ja nun auch eine Kante und konnte nicht mit jedem gut. Also das ist das, was dahinter stand. Ich frage jetzt nicht jeden einzelnen ab, ob ich da seine OK kriege oder nicht.
Das ist ja tragisch. Das heißt, diese Aufnahmen – also ein Teil davon kann ich mich erinnern, unter anderem die Feierlichkeiten in der Kabine. Die hat man auch später noch hin und wieder, gibt es da Schnipse, die man sehen kann mit einem sehr wenig bekleideten Lothar Matthäus sozusagen. Und der Pokal, der später noch von vielen geküsst wird, ist einer Delikatenstelle seines Körpers angebracht. Aber das heißt, diese Schnipse, diese Aufnahmen, die werden sich nicht in unser kollektives Gedächtnis einbrennen können, weil es nicht verfügbar ist.
Leider nicht. Das gehört wirklich mit zum Appell, sich die fünf Tage im Jahr zu gönnen.
Das war jetzt, glaube ich, die beste Fremdung. In welchem Jahr war das mit dem Sammai-Appell?
Wir trauen jetzt schon in die Festivalgeschichte ein, aber das sind so Sachen, die großartig sind. Wir haben nämlich genauso in einem Jahr, das war vor fünf Jahren, Schätze gezeigt aus dem brasilianischen Fußball. Da gab es sowas, wie früher Vorfilme in den deutschen Kinos eine Rolle gespielt haben, was in der Wochenschau gelaufen ist. Gab es in Brasilien die Tradition, dass immer die besten Fußballszenen der Woche vor den Filmen auf die Leimer gebracht wurden. Das Kanal 100 hieß das Ganze. Wir haben dadurch, dass wir einen engen Bezug haben zu dem Leiter des Festivals in Rio, Kontakt bekommen zu den Produzenten dieser Wochenschauen und haben die besten Ausschnitte aus diesen Wochenschauen hier bei uns zeigen können. Das war wirklich auch grandios.
Dann lassen wir zurückkommen zu Filmen, die man sich auch jetzt noch zur Gemüte führen kann. Wir werden noch ganz viel Werbung für das 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival machen. Wer jetzt noch nicht Lust hat, dahin zu kommen, der ist sowieso selber schuld. Was gibt es denn noch an verfügbaren Filmen, die ihr gerne herausheben möchtet?
Möchtest du schon ein Lieblingsfilm von dir sagen, Ina, vielleicht aus der Zeit?
Ich wollte noch mal auf einen anderen Regisseur eingehen, weil du gesagt hast, wir überlegen immer, eine Retrospektive zu Ken Loach zu machen. Wir haben tatsächlich einmal eine Retrospektive zu einem Regisseur gemacht, der vielleicht nicht so bekannt ist. Johann Kramer heißt er und wir haben einen ganz großen Fan auch bei uns im Team, unser Kollege Christoph. Er ist ein niederländischer Regisseur, der sehr viele Werbefilme und Kurzfilme gemacht hat, aber eben auch drei Langfilme, von denen zumindest einer, auch mit der Goldenen Elf, mit dem Publikumspreis ausgezeichnet wurde, mal im Jahr 2005. Das ist der Film The Other Final. Und zwar ist es parallel zum WM-Finale Deutschland-Brasilien 2002. Auf der anderen Seite der Welt sind die beiden Teams gegeneinander angetreten, die ganz am Ende der FIFA-Weltrangliste stehen, nämlich Montserrat und Bhutan. Genau. Und im Himalaya treffen sie sich und spielen dieses andere Finale. Und es ist ein ganz, ganz toller Dokumentarfilm über dieses Spiel eben. Genau, den wollte ich jetzt nochmal aus dem Jahr 2005 auch.
Ich setze an, und zwar gibt es einen weiteren Regisseur, ähnlich wie Johann Kramer, der uns schon mit mehreren Werken Beglück hat. Das ist Aljosha Pause. Wir sind auf ihn gestoßen, weil er Dokumentationen gemacht hat über Randbereiche des Fußballs, nämlich Alkoholismus im Fußball und auch Homophobie im Fußball. Da hat er sehr sehenswerte Reportagen zugemacht. Die haben wir dann auch vorgestellt, Homophobie im Fußball. Das war für uns auch ein Begleitthema beim Festival 2010. Und dann hat er uns einen sehr schönen Dokumentarfilm geschenkt, kann man sagen, Tommy Tzisou aus dem Jahr 2011. Ein ganz besonderer Film und ein ganz besonderer Fußballer, der porträtiert wird, Thomas Bräuch, der sowohl bei Gladbach als auch bei Köln unter anderem gespielt hat, sich in allen Situationen vor die Kamera stellt. Also das heißt, wir sind sehr nah an seinem Privatleben, bekommen seine Trennung vor Augen geführt von seiner Freundin als auch die Ups und Downs in seiner Fußballerkarriere eine große Rolle spielen. Seine Selbstzweifel werden dokumentiert, aber dann eben auch das Happy End, nämlich dass er nach Australien wechselt, für Brisbane spielt und dort überaus erfolgreich nacheinander das Tor des Jahres schießt, Fußballer des Jahres wird Meister, und heute, ich habe ihn vor kurzer Zeit widersprechen können, ein sehr glücklicher Mensch zu sein scheint. Und Aljosha hat es halt über einen längeren Zeitraum ihn begleitet. Der Film hatte bei uns Weltpremiere und ist auch heute noch sehenswert.
Absolut und tatsächlich Thomas Bräuch, ja Gast des zuletzt erschienenen Tribünengesprächs in Ausgabe 29, habe ich mit ihm gesprochen und hatte tatsächlich die Mammutaufgabe vor mir, angesichts dieser wirklich tollen Dokumentation, die ihn über so einen langen Zeitraum begleitet, sowohl neue Dinge mit ihm zu besprechen, als auch mich mit der Tiefe, die diese Dokumentation vorweisen konnte, irgendwie messen zu lassen. Ob das geklappt hat, das darf nicht ich beurteilen, das kann nur jeder Hörerin und jeder Hörer beurteilen, aber das ist jetzt eine interessante Synchronität, die ich aber auch erwartet hatte. Es ist eine ganz tolle Dokumentation – Tom meets Sisu. Und im letzten Tribünengespräch war eben Thomas Bräuch zu Gast. Und wir haben dann noch mal auf eine andere Art und Weise versucht, auch seine Karriere aufzuarbeiten. Ich hoffe, dass sich beides eigentlich ganz gut ergänzt. Zumindest wurde mir das jetzt rückgemeldet von vielen Hörern und Hörern, die auch die Dokumentation damals gesehen hatten und gesagt haben, super, das war jetzt noch mal so ein bisschen Teil 2 in Audioform, in akustischer Form.
Wir haben bis jetzt wenig über Trainer gesprochen, die auf der Leinbach gelandet sind. Da ist Aljosha Pause dann wieder zu nennen. Und zwar der Film heißt Trainer und porträtiert drei Männer, die im deutschen Profibereich auch schon eine Menge erlebt haben. Gar nicht so in der ersten Reihe stehen der Trainer gerade. Das ist einerseits der Stefan Schmidt gewesen, der unter anderem in der Zeit, als der Film läuft oder spielt, in Pallaborn Trainer war. Dann müssten wir beide Hälften der Trainer von Heidenheim, auch Schmidt, aber mit vornem Frank, glaube ich, ganz, ganz, ganz toller Typ, der in dem Film porträtiert wird. Und dann eben auch noch André Schubert, der ja nun wieder in Braunschweig harte Aufgabe vor sich hat. Alle drei werden durch viele Stationen begleitet. Und Ayosha schafft es, da doch sehr nahe ranzukommen und sehr intime Portraits für die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu präsentieren. Also da sind wir, glaube ich, schon im Jahr 2014. Aber da ist noch ein weiterer Film zu nennen, der in dem Zeitraum sehr, sehr wichtig war, nämlich eine ganz großartige Kinderkomödie, die aber fast für Erwachsene noch besser geeignet ist. The Liverpool Goalie, ein norwegischer Film über einen kleinen Jungen, der nicht Fußball spielen kann, aber Fußball begeistert ist, Panini-Bilder sammelt, aber auch nicht. Er ist eine wunderbare Fußballerin und er darf als Ersatztorwart in einem entscheidenden Spiel mitspielen. Filme mit herben schwarzen Humor, sodass man Kindern bis zehn mal die Augen zuhalten muss. Aber...
Und sie ist eine wunderbare Fußballerin. Und er darf als Ersatztorwart in einem entscheidenden Spiel mitspielen.
Und da war das Schöne auch, dass wir versuchen ja wirklich, deswegen haben wir es inzwischen auch geschafft, dass wir wirklich sagen können, es ist ein Festival, nämlich zu jedem Film auch ein Regisseur oder ein Darsteller oder jemand, der bei dem Film mitgearbeitet hat, einzuladen. Und auch bei Liverpool Goalie war es so, dass die Produktion es geschafft hat, uns die Regisseurin und die beiden jungen Hauptdarsteller nach Berlin zu holen. Und das ist natürlich immer ganz besonders, wenn man dann hinterher noch eine Frage-Antwort-Runde hat und dementsprechend noch weiter eintauchen kann in das, was man vorher gesehen hat.
Ja, das sieht man mal. Von dem Film zum Beispiel hatte ich jetzt noch gar nichts gehört. Da muss ich mir jetzt alles nebenher zusammen googeln. Da sieht man mal. Also 2014 war ich definitiv schon tief in der Fußball-Blaze drin. Da hatte ich mich schon dafür entschieden, das zu probieren, mit dem Sportjournalisten da sein. Und dennoch flutschen einem solche Dinge einfach durch. Interessant.
Dafür hast du ja uns eingeladen.
Wirklich.
Ina bringt das auf den Punkt.
Ich habe noch einen Film aus dem Jahr 2016, der mir sehr gut gefallen hat, der auch unseren Preis gewonnen hat. Das ist der Film Zwei-Kämpfer. Es ist ein Dokumentarfilm über arbeitslose Fußballer. Also, das war etwas, was ich so auch noch nicht gesehen habe. Von einem jungen Berliner Regisseur, Mehdi Ben-Hadj Jilali. Und der politiert eben vier Spieler, glaube ich vor allen Dingen, die sich in so einem Camp für arbeitslose Fußballer fit halten. Und es geht eben darum, wie reagieren ihre Familien darauf? Wie können sie doch wieder einen Einstieg schaffen? Also, Niko Frommner ist vielleicht ein Begriff, der ist dabei. Christian Mikolajczak, die auch sehr offen eben darüber sprechen, wie die Situation ist. Das ist irgendwie so ein anderes Bild, was man mal bekommt von Profi-Fußballern. Und wie schnell das dann eben auch vorbei sein kann mit dem ganzen Hype und was man dann eigentlich so macht. Die waren auch zu Gast beim Festival. Also, es war eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung.
Ja, sehr interessantes Thema. Definitiv. Das kann ich auch wirklich jedem nur ans Herz legen, sich damit auch ein bisschen zu befassen. Das zeigt auch noch mal generell nicht nur der Bereich, was man eigentlich nach der Karriere macht, oder was man, wenn man aus unterschiedlichsten Gründen eine Pause in seiner Karriere hat und den Weg wieder zurückfinden möchte in den Profi-Fußball, sondern auch die Frage, was eigentlich jenseits von dem Profi-Fußball geht, den wir alle verfolgen. Nämlich erste Bundesliga, vielleicht noch ein bisschen zweite Bundesliga. Was passiert eigentlich darunter, weil das ganz andere Biografien sind, zum Teil auch andere Typen an Sportlern und weil da nämlich die eigentlichen Probleme anfangen, weil es da dann eher um Existenzen geht und um die Frage, was mache ich denn mit meinem restlichen Leben? Ich habe meinen Körper und meine nicht vorhandene Ausbildung dem Fußball gewidmet und jetzt sehe ich mich aber der Realität entgegengestellt, dass ich mit anderen Dingen meinen Lebensunterhalt finanzieren muss. Da liegen vielleicht die größeren Geschichten und die größeren Dramen, vielleicht aber auch Erfolgsgeschichten, als im Profifußball, der in seiner ganz eigenen Welt lebt, auch mit anderen Voraussetzungen für das weitere Leben.
Ja, total. Vor allem, wenn man dann wirklich erfolgreich ist, hat man ja eigentlich, wenn man halbwegs mit Geld umgehen kann, auch ausgesorgt. Aber wenn man eben so semi-erfolgreich war und das ist dann plötzlich zu Ende, dann steht man tatsächlich da. Und es war eben auch bei dem Film tatsächlich ein großes Thema, wie reagiert eigentlich das Umfeld plötzlich auf diese neue Situation.
Ja, sehr, sehr spannendes Thema. Sehr, sehr spannend. Jetzt sind wir schon im Jahr 2016. Das heißt, jetzt geht es um aktuellste Streifen. Weiß gar nicht, ob man das noch so sagt. Wen würdet ihr gerne da noch herausheben?
Also ich würde gerne noch den einzigen nicht-Dokumentarfilm, der bei uns gewonnen hat, herausheben. Leider auch ein Film, den man, ich weiß nicht wie noch sehen kann, höchstwahrscheinlich, wenn man Glück hat und in Italien in einem Unterhaltungselektronik-Kaufhaus unterwegs ist und sich eine alte DVD kauft. Es ist The Lost World Cup aus dem Jahr 2011, aber der ist dann tatsächlich erst 2014 ins Kino gekommen und die Geschichte ist vollkommen irre. Also es geht um die Weltmeisterschaft 1942, die keiner mehr so richtig in Erinnerung hat.
Vielleicht, weil es sie nicht gab.
Das weiß man nicht. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall einen hundertminütigen Film dazu, dass es sie gab. Und zwar das Endspielbestreiten Deutschland gegen Patagonien und die deutsche Mannschaft ist natürlich vollgestopft von irgendwelchen unerträglichen Nazis, aber einem sehr gut aussehenden Torwart, der sich in die Tochter des pathogenischen Trainers verliebt. Und das ist so die Randgeschichte, die, also Forscher sind auf eine Filmrolle gestoßen, weil, wie nennt man das, wenn man Saurier aus dem Boden holt?
Ausgrabungen.
Ausgrabungen, genau. Bei Ausgrabungen. Auf die Filmrolle gestoßen und können es einfach nicht fassen, dass tatsächlich, sowohl in der FIFA-Geschichte, es werden dann tatsächlich auch Joseph Blatter beispielsweise interviewt, der auch gesagt hat, er hätte viel zu spät davon erfahren, dass da zwischen 38 und 50 doch eine Weltmeisterschaft stattgefunden hat, nämlich die in Argentinien, Patagonien. Und der Film ist ganz zauberhaft gemacht. Man weiß ab der ersten Minute, dass es gefaked ist und trotzdem, also beispielsweise Gary Lineker erzählt darüber, wie sein Vater ihm davon immer schon erzählt hat, dass es so ein bedeutendes Spiel war, gut gegen böse und es ist ja eine ganz tolle Geschichte.
In dieser tollen Schnittstelle zwischen Dokumentation und Spielfilm, die man dann Mockumentary nennen kann, wenn man möchte, also ein fiktives Ereignis, wird im Stil einer Dokumentation dargestellt und schafft es dann tatsächlich im besten Fall, dass man sich am Ende des Films fragt, könnte das jetzt nicht doch so passiert sein? Ja, das stimmt. Da passieren einem auch manchmal Dinge, wo man sich denkt, ist das jetzt wirklich so zustande gekommen oder habe ich mir das gerade eingebildet? Aber so ist das manchmal im Leben. Ina, hast du noch was auf dem Zettel, was du gerne noch vorstellen wollen würdest?
Nö, ich glaube, ich würde eher zum aktuellen Programm übergehen, wenn Birger keine Best-of-Filme mehr zu nennen hat.
Ich bin auch an dem Punkt angelangt, dass wir 2019 eintauchen können.
Sehr gut. Ina, sag uns doch mal erst mal, wann findet denn eigentlich das 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival in Berlin statt?
Das 16. ist es und es findet statt vom 21. bis 25. März im Babylon-Kino in Berlin-Mitte. Ja genau, zum 16. Mal. Und wir haben Spiel- und Dokumentarfilme aus aller Welt, über 70 Filme insgesamt im premiären Rahmenprogramm, hoffentlich ein grün Rasen vor dem Kino.
Okay, das heißt, man kann sich schon in Kürze, wenn man das hier direkt nach der Ausstrahlung hört, überlegen, ob man da noch die Reise nach Berlin antreten will, oder wenn ihr Berlinerin oder Berliner seid, dann sollte das sowieso ab jetzt auf eurem Zettel spätestens stehen, da mal vorbeizugucken. Und was erwartet jetzt den geneigten Kinofan in diesen wenigen Tagen nächste Woche?
Also genau, wie gesagt, über 70 Filme haben wir immer, basteln wir Schwerpunkt rein. Manchmal legen wir die vorher fest und sagen, wir würden gerne mal was zu einem bestimmten Thema machen. So war es in diesem Jahr. Da haben wir gesagt, Frauen im Fußball ist unser Thema. Oft ergeben die sich aber auch im Rahmen der Sichtung, weil man plötzlich merkt, wir haben total viele, total gute Filme, die sich mit Regionalliga-Fußball befassen oder mit NRW vereinen. Wir hatten glaube ich schon mehrfach den Schwerpunkt Großbritannien, weil immer so viele starke Filme aus Großbritannien kommen. Aber in diesem Jahr war es anders. Wir haben uns eben vorher festgelegt und gesagt, wir möchten was zu Frauen im Fußball machen. Wir haben da eine Reihe zusammengestellt mit ungefähr zehn Filmen, ganz unterschiedlichster Art. Den schwedischen Film Football i Nöd och Lust habe ich vorhin schon ganz kurz vorgestellt. Das wird die Eröffnung sein der Reihe am Freitagabend, also dem 22. März ist es um 20.45 Uhr. Darum werden wir ein Gespräch stricken. Das Filmteam ist da, die Regisseurin und auch Protagonistinnen des Films. Aber sonst wird Frauenfußball in aller Welt gezeigt in dieser Reihe, in Spiel- und Dokumentarfilmen. Wir haben zum Beispiel einen Film aus dem Iran, Arak Esad, Cold Sweat ist der englische Titel. Da geht es um die Kapitänin des Frauen-Kleinfeld-Nationalteams, die mit ihrer Mannschaft zu einem Finale nach der Asienmeisterschaft reisen möchte und am Flughafen aufgehalten wird, weil ihr Ehemann oder ihr Getrennt verweigert hat ihr die Ausreise. Das ist ein gesellschaftskritischer Film über die Situation von Frauen im Iran, wo der Fußball dann auch wieder nur eine Randrolle spielt, aber für sie total wichtig ist und in dem Sinne natürlich auch ein Fußballfilm, weil er immer präsent ist, weil es natürlich um ihre Ausreise zu diesem Finale geht. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man da dauernd Fußballspielende Frauen sieht zum Beispiel. Wir haben noch einen Spielfilm im Programm Com des Garcons, der führt uns ins Frankreich Ende der 60er Jahre, wo eines der ersten Frauenteams über Haupt gegründet wird, weil Fußballspielen auch in den 60ern in Frankreich noch verboten war. Und in Reims kommen dann ein paar tollkühne Frauen auf die Idee, doch mal Fußball zu spielen und dieser Film begleitet sie dabei. Das ist ein Film, der läuft sogar schon so ein bisschen vor dem Festival, also man muss gar nicht noch bis zum Donnerstag warten. Der läuft schon am Montag den 18.3. im Citykino in Wedding. Es ist eine Kooperationsveranstaltung mit dem deutsch-französischen Jugendwerk und dem Centre Francais im Wedding. Genau, auch mit Gästen, zu denen kann Birger vielleicht was sagen. Der steckt mehr in den Gästen für diesen Abend drin.
Auch da ist das Frauenthema noch mal extra im Mittelpunkt und es sind Spielerinnen von Turbine Potsdam, zwei Spielerinnen, die vor Ort sind. Ich kann jetzt noch nicht mit den Namen glänzen, weil es noch nicht letztendlich bestätigt ist, vor allem auch was die französischen Gäste angeht. Aber das werden auch zwei weibliche Personen sein, die entweder in der Geschäftsleitung eines Französischen Fußball-Profi-Vereins sind und eine Spielerin aus Frankreich und darüber hinaus ist der Regisseur von Comme des Garçons vor Ort sowie die französische Botschafterin. Also es ist schon ziemlich hoch besetzt, aber der Film lohnt sich allemal. Es ist eine sehr heitere Komödie, aber eben auch mit einem Bezug zu der Geschichte des französischen Fußballs sehr ähnlich wie bei uns. Bis 1970 ist es in Frankreich nicht erlaubt für Frauen im Diggerbetrieb Fußball zu spielen und das Ganze wird auf eine ganz besondere Art nochmal vorgestellt.
Genau, dann umfasst diese Schwerpunktreihe eben auch noch ein paar Dokumentarfilme. Ich will nicht im Einzelnen jetzt auf alle eingehen, aber die Reihe entführt uns wirklich in alle Gegenden der Welt. Also wir sehen Frauen in Indien, auf Zanzibar, in Kabul, in Venezuela und was tatsächlich alle diese Filme zeigen, ist, was für eine starke Rolle der Fußball im Leben dieser Frauen spielt und wie der Fußball auch eine Befreiung ist für diese Frauen aus Armut oder natürlich auch aus sehr patriarchalen Gesellschaften.
Damit wissen wir, was uns jetzt bei diesem Filmfestival erwartet. Erklärt mir mal, Ina, fang du gerne mal an, wie läuft jetzt der Auswahlprozess ab? Ihr habt vorhin schon von den vielen Einreichungen gesprochen. Wie seid ihr da organisiert? Wer entscheidet letztlich, welcher Film dann gezeigt wird?
Also, wie haben wir vorhin schon gesagt, wir haben auch noch ein anderes Leben, wo wir hauptberuflich unterwegs sind. Und das ist tatsächlich bei allen so. Wir sind ein Kernteam von sechs bis acht Leuten, würde ich sagen. Wir organisieren uns sehr viel übers Internet. Also, wir haben so eine Google-Liste, in der alle Filme stehen und alle Sichtungslinks stehen. Das hat sich tatsächlich sehr verbessert in den letzten Jahren. Wir haben fast nur noch digitale Sichtungskopien. Vor zwei, drei Jahren sogar noch anders. Da hatten wir noch sehr viele DVDs, die wir dann irgendwie hin und her tauschen mussten. Aber jetzt haben wir einfach Links, wo jeder darauf zugreifen kann. Wir schreiben Bewertungen in diese Liste rein und wir versuchen uns eigentlich dann einmal in der Woche zu treffen, die Filme zu besprechen. Und die Regel ist sozusagen, dass wir immer sagen, es müssen eigentlich drei Leute den Film gesehen und bewertet haben. Und dann ist es eine gemeinschaftliche Entscheidung.
Das heißt aber, jeder der über 200 Filme wird von mindestens dreien aus dem Team von euch gesehen?
So wird es mal versucht. Also, wenn wir jetzt merken, zwei Leute haben ihn gesehen und sind total einer Meinung, dann ist es auch in Ordnung. Es sind auch nicht alles Langfilme, also unter den 250 sind auch Kurzfilme und mittellang Filme. Aber es gibt viel zu gucken.
Und vor allem das alles macht ihr ja dann in eurer Freizeit. Wie lange dauert denn dann dieser Auswahlprozess?
Also, wir starten so mit Filmanfragen, würde ich sagen, ab September vielleicht. Und dann so Ende des Jahres fangen wir an zu sichten. Also, viele nutzen eigentlich immer die Weihnachtspause so ein bisschen, um ganz viele Filme zu gucken. Und dann im Januar wird eigentlich jede freie Minute genutzt, um die Filme zu sichten und zu besprechen. Weil wir müssen so bis Mitte Februar ungefähr durch sein mit dem Auswahlprozess. Also, unsere Einreichungen dürfen bis Mitte Januar kommen. Aber wie gesagt, viele Filme fragen wir auch an und haben wir dann schon vorher. Und bis Mitte Februar müssen wir dann wirklich durch sein, weil dann müssen wir noch die Programmierung machen, die Filme zusagen und dann das Programmheft machen. Also, es ist dann auch schon ganz schnell März, wenn es Mitte Februar ist, es ist auch schon ganz schnell jetzt Mitte März, das heißt, es bleibt nicht viel Zeit, ja.
Und Birger, erklär mir mal ein bisschen die Hintergründe zum Fußballfilmfestival 11mm. Das wird in der Freizeit gemacht, wer steht da dahinter, wie kam es dazu und wie finanziert ihr dann die Filme? Wir haben ja vorhin schon mal kurz darüber gesprochen, wie teuer es sein kann, einen Film zu zeigen.
Ganz kurz auf die Geschichte eingehend, also wir haben 2002 hier in Prenzlauer Berg einen Verein gegründet, der sich Bode und Spiele e.V. nennt, Verein für Fußball und Kultur. Wo es in der Anfangsphase eigentlich darum ging, zusammen Fußball zu spielen, zusammen Fußball zu gucken und darüber hinaus zu denken, was kann man eigentlich noch rund um diesen Sport machen. Und da waren gleich mehrere Kulturaktivisten unterwegs, die verschiedene Ideen hatten. Der British Council spielte eine große Rolle, weil er schon sehr früh den Bode und Spiele als Partner im Vorfeld zur WM 2006 geladen hat zu mehreren Veranstaltungen und auch zu gemeinsamen Ideenwerkstätten. Und im Jahr 2003 ist dann die Idee entstanden, dieses Fußballfilmfestival zu machen, was auch möglich war, dadurch, dass der British Council sagte, gut, machen wir für euch, wir mieten ein Kino an. Unsere Bedingung ist, ihr zeigt bei diesem Festival nur britische Filme. Und das war eine Vorgabe, mit der wir sehr gut leben konnten, weil wir zuerst dachten, es gibt nur britische Filme. Das war dann schon mal klasse, dass wir wussten, Qualität stimmt, das Ganze ist durchfinanziert. Das war zuerst sehr bescheiden in einem Kleinkino im H-Markt hier in Berlin. Und wir hatten im ersten Jahr rund 400 Zuschauer. Aber was noch viel wichtiger war, war, dass die Zuschauer entzückt waren von dem, was sie da gesehen haben. Und wir von außen ganz viel Zuspruch bekommen haben. Auch Journalisten, die gesagt haben, Mensch, wollt ihr da nicht dran weiterarbeiten, dass es nicht einmalig bleibt. Und dann haben wir uns richtig, da waren wir auch so acht bis zehn Personen stark, auf die Reise gemacht, im doppelten Sinne. Also quer durch die Internetwelt, aber eben auch andere Festivals besucht, um zu gucken, ob es noch mehr Fußballfilme gibt. Und sind dann auch immer mehr gestoßen. Wir hatten von Anfang an den Anspruch, nicht nur die heute schon häufiger genannten Perlen aus der langen Fußballfilmgeschichte zu zeigen, sondern neue Erscheinungen auf die Bühne zu bringen. Und ja, da ist eben aus dieser spleenigen Idee, was ziemlich groß ist, entstanden. Für uns ist es etwas ganz Großes, für die, die immer noch dabei sind. Aber es ist halt wirklich, es ist an der Grenze. Also das, was du mit Rasenfunk auch erlebt hast in der Anfangszeit, man weiß nicht, wie man das Ganze finanzieren soll. Man kann trotzdem von dieser Sucht nicht lassen. Und steckt so viel Zeit und Leidenschaft rein und Arbeit, das ist schon ganz gewaltig. Und es ist halt immer größer geworden. Wir haben Anruf bekommen von dem Kino Babylon, die einen großen Saal haben und zwei weitere Säle, was für uns ziemlich klasse ist, sodass wir eben auch kleine independent Produktionen in den kleineren Sälen laufen lassen können und im großen Saal dann wirklich Festival spielen können, in dem wir Musik haben und Gäste, die wir auf die Bühne holen können und 400 Leute da Platz haben, das ist ganz toll. Und das war für uns dann auch nochmal ein richtiger Quantensprung. Und das Ganze musste aber eben auch finanziert werden. Es ist nicht möglich, dieses Festival alleine über die Zuschauer zu finanzieren, über die Eintrittsgraden. Und da sind wir sehr dankbar, möchte ich an dieser Stelle einfach nochmal sagen, dass die DFB Kulturstiftung uns in diesem Jahr zum zehnten Mal begleitet. Das sorgt dafür, dass wir eine Grundfinanzierung haben, heißt, dass wir schaffen, die Filme bezahlen zu können und auch die besagten Gäste einladen zu können. Alles noch in einem sehr bescheidenen Rahmen und so, wie es Ina vorhin schon auch gesagt hat, wir sind eigentlich alle ehrenamtlich unterwegs, können uns zum Schluss eine kleine Aufwandsentschädigung zahlen, aber ansonsten ist das schon ziemlich irre, was wir da machen.
Und dadurch, dass ein eingetragener Verein dahinter steht, ist ja auch klar, dass es keine gewinnorientierte Veranstaltung sein kann, vor allem, weil er ja nicht gemeinnützig im Sinne des DFBs oder der FIFA sei. Da wird das nochmal anders interpretiert. Sondern man kann eben bei euch auch sicher sein, dass wenn man dieses Festival unterstützt durch Besuch oder andere Dinge, dass man da auch jetzt einer guten Sache etwas beisteuert und nicht einem Kommerzdrang irgendwie noch neues Feuer verleiht, sondern das ist bei euch eben anders gelagert.
Wir können einen Aufruf starten, was uns Jahr für Jahr am meisten Schwierigkeiten bereitet, außer dem normalen Programmierungsbetrieb, den wir haben, und Sichtungsbetrieb ist, Schauspielerinnen und Schauspieler, Regisseure und Regisseurinnen zu gewinnen, die bei uns in der Jury sitzen. Wir setzen unsere Jury meistens so zusammen, dass die Hälfte aus dem Fußballbereich kommt, die andere eher aus dem Filmbereich, aber es ist kolossal schwierig, Menschen zu finden, die an dem Tag, das letzte Tag des Festivals vor Ort sind und mit voten, sozusagen für die besten Kurzfilme des Jahres und wenn deine Hörerinnen und Hörer eng befreundete Leute aus dem Bereich Film haben, dürfen sie sich gerne an uns finden und bis nächstes Jahr wird die Jurybank dann schon bereitgestellt.
Also ganz spontan fallen mir schon mal drei Leute ein, ich weiß, sie sind Schauspieler, zum Teil im Film, zum Teil im Theater und Fußball begeistert, denn sie betreiben Fußballpodcasts. Bei Doppel-6 gibt es Hendrix von Bölzingslöwen und beim Brennerpass gibt es Maximilian Nofker und Rüdiger Rudolf. Herzliche Grüße an der Stelle. Wenn ihr das jetzt hören könnt, wenn nicht, dann werdet ihr bald von mir eine Nachricht bekommen und dann werde ich mal Kontakt herstellen. Das könnt ihr doch tatsächlich…
Genau, vielleicht dann nochmal so ein bisschen zum aktuellen Programm. Also ich habe jetzt ja die eine Schwerpunktreihe Frauen im Fußball vorgestellt. Wir haben tatsächlich noch eine zweite Schwerpunktreihe in diesem Jahr. Das ist das Thema Serien, weil auch der Fußballfilm – oder ist ja dann eine Serie, nicht mehr ein klassischer Film – aber auch dort gibt es immer mehr Serien. Also es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, wie viel in dem Bereich eigentlich auch meistens Dokumentarfilmserien produziert wird. Auf der Elf-Freunde war auch auf dem Cover Sunderland Till I Die eine sehr gute Serie von Netflix, die wir leider nicht zeigen können beim Festival, weil Netflix seine Serien nicht auf Festivals zeigen möchte. Aber wir haben ein paar andere tolle über Mannschaften, über Spieler und auch eine fiktive Serie, auch aus Schweden – nein, aus Norwegen kommt sie – über eine Frau, die ein Männerteam trainiert. Heimelbane heißt sie. Und dann das große Programm sind nationale und internationale Neuerscheinungen, also wirklich Fußballfilme aus den letzten zwei, drei Jahren, aus allen Ländern zu allen möglichen Themen, Spiele und Dokumentarfilme. Da ist wirklich für jeden und jede etwas dabei.
Das klingt alles so spannend, dass man sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, durch welche Kenfie ihr wahrscheinlich die letzten Jahre gehen musstet, um dieses Festival hinzustellen. Aber jeder, der sich kurz damit befasst und dann mal auch drüber nachdenkt, was es bedeutet, so etwas zu machen, der sieht dann doch, okay, das wird dann doch nicht so einfach sein. Birger, du hast vorhin erwähnt, dass es auch andere Fußballfilmfestivals gibt, die ihr in den Anfangszeiten dann besucht habt, um auch Einreichungen, neue Filme zu finden, euch inspirieren zu lassen. Wie verbreitet es es denn, so Filmfestivals mit dem Schwerpunkt, Fußball zu machen?
Nee, das ist ein Missverständnis. Also wir waren tatsächlich das erste Fußballfilmfestival und das nächste ist danach sechs Jahre später im Rio de Janeiro.
Ach, weltweit auch das erste.
Wir waren weltweit das erste, also kann man so mit viel Glück und Stolz sagen. Wir haben andere Festivals, also normale Filmfestivals besucht, wo dann auch mal beispielsweise, fällt mir jetzt ein, beim nordischen Filmfestival in Lübeck ein schwedischer Fußballfilm gezeigt wurde. Und dann haben wir eben gleich versucht, da Kontakt aufzunehmen und zu sagen, Mensch, habt ihr nicht Lust, den Film nächstes Jahr bei uns auch noch zu zeigen. Also das war die Reise, die wir gemacht haben. Es gibt mittlerweile 19 offizielle Fußballfilmfestivals weltweit. Und das geht wirklich über alle fünf Kontinente. Wir haben Festival in Kolumbien, Bogota, genauso wie in Beijing, in Sydney. Gibt es eins in Namibia, also da haben wir die anderen Kontinente. In Europa gibt es sowohl in Spanien als auch in der Schweiz sogar zwei mittlerweile. Basel, St. Gallen, Barcelona und Bilbao. Und das Schöne ist, wir hatten vor zwei Jahren hier ein Treffen aller Festivalmacher und Macherinnen. Und seitdem hat sich da auch so ein Freundeskreis aufgebaut, das wir natürlich wunderbar nutzen können. Das heißt, dass die lateinamerikanischen Festivaldirektoren uns ihre Tipps zuschicken, was gibt es Neues in Argentinien und in Chile. Und uns dann wiederum im März hier besuchen, um sich in erster Linie die europäischen Filme anzugucken, die sie sonst nicht sehen. Also, dass das Ganze gewachsen ist. Aber auch hier muss man sagen, es ist eine Randerscheinung, aber eine, die mit ganz viel Herz ausgefüllt wird. Es gibt kein Festival, das tatsächlich es schafft, jemanden hauptamtlich anzustellen, um das zu betreiben.
Das ist ja wirklich interessant und dass ihr weltweit die ersten wart, ist natürlich Wahnsinn. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Und wie stehen eurer Meinung nach die Chancen, dass sich dieses Festival auch mal aus dem Berliner Kontext löst? Ich glaube gerade schon, erkennt zu können, dass er dann die Frage doof ist, weil ihr das ja alles ehrenamtlich macht. Wann sollt ihr das auch noch in andere Städte bringen? Aber gäbe es dafür denn überhaupt die Möglichkeit, dass man jetzt sagen könnte, vielleicht hat ja sogar auch der eine oder andere Hörer oder Hörerin da draußen Lust, da mitzuhelfen, vielleicht sogar Kontakte, dann das Programm des Festivals auch an anderen Standorten verfügbar zu machen?
Also das Festivale war schon häufig auf Tour, wir werden häufig eingeladen, gerade so im Vorfeld von Europa- und Weltmeisterschaften. Jetzt haben wir im letzten Jahr zwei 11mm-Fußballfilme und Tourfestivals in Russland gehabt, in Rostov und Kazan. Wir waren in der Schweiz, Österreich, Ukraine, Polen, in Paris, in Rio de Janeiro, also das ist schon so, dass wir dann wirklich gebucht werden, für einige Tage dann ein Filmprogramm zusammenstellen und das häufig in Zusammenarbeit beispielsweise mit dem Auswärtigen Amt oder dem Goethe-Institut oder den jeweiligen Jugendwerken der Nation dann ausführen als Auftragsarbeit. Aber dass das Ganze etabliert werden kann, woanders, dazu bräuchte es tatsächlich den großen Finanziell. Der sagt, Mensch, das ist so eine irre Idee und da bauen wir drum herum noch was Gutes und dann schaffen wir es, dass zwei, drei, vier Leute von euch davon leben können und das auch eben tagtäglich machen.
Ja, ich wollte noch sagen, wir sind auch nicht nur in der Welt unterwegs, sondern tatsächlich auch manchmal in Deutschland, in anderen Städten. In Dortmund haben wir regelmäßig Filme gezeigt, im Deutschen Fußballmuseum schon. Oder in Mannheim fand mal so ein kleiner Ableger das Festival statt, aber das sind eben immer Einzelanfragen, bei denen wir dann auch gucken müssen, wie kriegen wir die eigentlich unter bei dem, was wir sonst alles noch so tun.
Ich habe jetzt mitbekommen, im Oktober gab es noch ein regionales Fußballfilmfestival. Das erste Fußballfilmfestival im Revierspiel Abdat-Dingen. Da konnte man dann unter anderem Being Mario, Götze und Ennards eine Zebra-Legende sehen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr in Kontakt mit den Machern davon seid, das war auch glaube ich im Rahmen des Fußballmuseums alles aufgezogen. Gibt es Anhaltspunkte zu glauben, dass sowas jetzt vielleicht zunimmt, dass man, wenn man sich für Fußball auch in einem kulturellen Umfeld interessiert, mehr Angebote in Deutschland bekommt?
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Bedarf, das kriegen wir mit durch unsere Arbeit, also wirklich die Kollegen aus den Lernzentren als auch in den Fanprojekten sagen, Mensch, das ist ein tolles Medium, um in Kontakt zu kommen, also jetzt auch rein vom pädagogischen Ansatz her, aber auch sonst gibt es im Aufglaub oder im Nachklang eines Festivals immer wieder Anfragen aus Bielefeld oder aus Passau oder sonst wo, man sagt immer Flensburg und Passau, ob es nicht möglich wäre, sowas in ihren Städten auch zu machen. Es wird tatsächlich ein bisschen konkreter, es gibt zwei Städte, wo wir überlegen sind, inwiefern wir das umsetzen könnten, das für drei bis fünf Tage zu machen, aber ja, Bedarf ist da und inzwischen ist auch viel Stoff da und da muss man einfach dazu sagen, wir haben in den vergangenen 16 Jahren hochgerechnet zwischen 1500 und 2000 Filme gesehen und die könnten überall auf anderen Festivals auftauchen, weil wir sagen können, da gibt es die Kontakte, wir haben den Kontakt zu den einzelnen Filme verleihen, wir wissen, welche Qualität die Filme haben, also das wäre so gesehen administrativ zu leisten.
Und kann man euch als Privatperson noch anders unterstützen, als dass man euch Schauspieler in die Jury setzt?
Also wie Birger schon gesagt hat, wir sind ja ein Verein Brot und Spiele e.V. Wir freuen uns immer über Mitstreiterinnen und Mitstreiter, die auch Lust haben, sich im Verein zu engagieren und dann eben auch mit Sichten beim Festival aushelfen. Also für dieses Jahr sind wir jetzt gut aufgestellt mit Helferinnen und Helfern. Aber so grundsätzlich freuen wir uns immer über Menschen, die genauso verrückt nach Fußball und Film oder Fußball und Kultur sind wie wir und einfach Lust haben, sich ab und zu mit uns zu treffen und an diesem Festival oder anderen Projekten zu stricken.
Darüber hinaus kann man wirklich sagen, verbunden mit deiner Frage, also wenn Personen in ihrem Umfeld beispielsweise Programmkino-Betreiber kennen oder Leute, die in kulturellen Institutionen arbeiten, Zugang zu Kinos haben, die dürfen sich gerne bei uns melden und dann kann man gucken, inwiefern wir es wirklich schaffen, dann 11mm on Tour zu schicken.
Das wäre wirklich was Feines, man kann euch auch folgen auf Twitter, mit den Ziffern 11mm und MM für Millimeter, ein sehr eingängiger Twitter-Handle. Generell sollte man so ein bisschen im Auge behalten, was ihr so alles macht, denn es ist bemerkenswert, so etwas über so eine lange Zeit aufrechtzuhalten, auch mit diesem Aufwand. Ihr habt das jetzt so ein bisschen, ich finde, fast schon kleiner geredet, als ihr hättet müssen. Es ist unglaublich, dass ihr das schafft, auf die Beine zu stellen und dass ihr dann noch Zeit habt, für ein langes Tribünengespräch, unmittelbar vor dem Festival. Und ich hatte es ja schon angedeutet, für uns war das Ganze jetzt auch länger als für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, durch so einige technische Ungereimtheiten, die wir da noch auflösen müssten. Also wirklich faszinierend. Ich kann an der Stelle dann auch sagen, dass bei diesem Fußballfilmfestival ich auch einen kleinen Part haben werde. Im Rahmen einer Podiumsdiskussion werde ich auch noch in der nächsten Schlusskonferenz drüber erzählen. Aber ehrlich gesagt, mich braucht es da als Argument nicht, um da hinzukommen. Die Argumente habt ihr jetzt schon vorher geliefert. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Ja, ich freue mich auch, euch dann wiederzusehen. Auch Brot und Spiele. Da machen wir noch mal was Eigenes dazu. Das ist sowieso ein interessantes Thema. Abschließend würde mich noch interessieren, wenn ihr euch etwas wünschen könntet, was sich im Bezug auf kulturellen Betrieb und Fußball in den nächsten fünf Jahren verändert. Habt ihr da konkrete Vorstellungen, Ina?
Also es hat, glaube ich, gar nicht nur mit Fußball und Kultur zu tun, sondern generell mit dem Kulturbetrieb, dass irgendwie die Bezahlung so ein bisschen besser wird und die finanzielle Ausstattung, also nicht nur die Honorare, sondern einfach auch so ein bisschen Planungssicherheit für all die Kulturschaffenden da draußen, die sehr viel von ihrem Enthusiasmus leben müssen und einfach auf fehlende Sicherheit haben und nicht wissen, wie findet das nächste Jahr statt. Da sind wir ja sogar noch ganz gut ausgestattet mit so einem Partner wie der DFB Kulturstiftung, wo man wirklich weiß, jährlich sind die eigentlich wieder dabei, aber grundsätzlich würde ich mir da so ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit und Akzeptanz auch wünschen für das, was ganz viele Leute mit ganz viel Herdspurt auf die Beine stellen in der Republik.
Ja, Birger?
Ich schließe mich an darüber hinaus, träume ich immer noch davon, dass die Sache, die so oft schon genannt wird, tatsächlich mal wahr wird, nämlich dass es eine neue Generation von Fußballfunktionären geben wird. Leider sind auch die, die jetzt 40 oder Mitte 40 sind, nicht großartig anders als die Vorgänger, sonst würde ich nämlich hoffen, dass diese Leute, die in Geschäftsleitung von Bundesliga- und Zweitliga-Vereinen sitzen, ein Verständnis dafür entwickeln, was Fußballkultur alles bedeutet und eben auch Dinge wie ein Fußballpodcast oder ein Fußballfilmfestival unterstützen und merken, was das Fandasein noch alles mit sich bringen kann und wie viel Kreativität gegeben ist rund um den Fußball. Wir wissen das alle, aber leider ist es in den Vereinsleitungen immer noch nicht angekommen und da wären eben auch die wirtschaftlichen Mittel, um sowas zu unterstützen.
Da kann man sich natürlich nur anschließen. Da sitzen wir drei aber ja auch in einem gemeinsamen Boot. Das habt ihr ja auch schon gerade umrissen. Ich danke euch beiden. Das war zum einen Birger Schmidt, der Leiter des 11mm-Fußballfilmfestivals in Berlin ist, ehrenamtlich und noch viele andere Dinge, tolle Dinge tut. Birger, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne.
Das freut mich. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Ina Bargmann, die logischerweise auch beim 11mm-Fußballfilmfestival mitarbeitet. Ich habe das jetzt nur wiederholt, um diesen Namen häufig genug fallen gelassen zu haben, dass es mich allen Menschen einbrennt in den Gehirn. Ina, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Ja, vielen Dank für die Einladung. Und wir freuen uns auf nächste Woche auf das Festival und auf deinen Besuch.
Das tue ich ebenso. Das wird ganz, ganz großartig, euch dann dort zu sehen. Und auch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die das jetzt nach diesem Festival hören, nehmt euch das Thema an, schaut, was es da in eurer Gegend gibt, wie ihr vielleicht selber unterstützen könnt. Ich danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich danke für alle Unterstützerinnen und Unterstützer. Und hoffe, dieses Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch hat euch gefallen. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Bis bald mal wieder. Macht's gut, ciao.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.